sur le comportement de jérôme cahuzac
par exemple vis-à-vis de moi et les
conséquences que ça avait eu sur moi
quand en fait j'ai refusé ses avances
extrêmement en insistante main réserve
parlementaire a été réduite mais
quasiment vraiment au strict minimum
et ensuite quand on est l'un et l'autre
devenu ministre moi j'avais alerté
françois hollande j'avais alerté jean
marc ayrault j'avais alerté un certain
jean pierre moscovici non mais françois
hollande vous a dit quoi à ce moment là
mais ne croyez pas bien sûr qu'une
personne ne me croyait puisque jérôme
cahuzac raconté que nous avions eu une
histoire ensemble et que c'était moi qui
vivais très mal notre prétendue
séparation voyez il ya des choses c'est
tout simplement inaudi parce que tu as
sont les femmes allaient toujours tort
dans cette histoire n'a rien ça c'est
incroyable ça t'arrive web et moi tu
vois là je trouve qu'on a ouvert la
boîte de pandore ça et on a droit tout
et n'importe quoi il ya des vraies
victimes - de viol de harcèlement il ya
des femmes qui sont en souffrance qui
ont été humiliés et c'est gravissime il
faut être derrière ces femmes il faut d
inquiéter lieu mais là on m'a fait des
mesures d'aidé avance avec insistance
c'est quoi une avance avec insistance la
frontière d'un qe3 fait trop dur mais
c'est pas comme c'est pas que je la
prends pas c'est que c'est que elle dit
ça a un peu plusieurs années après à un
moment donné où la parole se libère il
est bien cassée loubert mais il faut
qu'à un moment donné on avance quelques
sénat même nom met d'accord à
ce qu'elles expliquent ce qui est grave
dans cette histoire c'est qu'elle dit
que ça et des répères pas bien sûr sa
vie après il est là le problème en train
de te dire qu'elle est alors entre
contre les avances extrêmement assistant
laurent jacot les biens non maghrébine
ont raison parce qu'elle a été minime si
elle sait comment un côté qu'elle s'est
plaint que j'étais ministre l'a vu tu
dis elle a été ministre après tu sais ce
qui s'est passé non mais on me dit sa
vie professionnelle à eta elle était
députée le devenu ministre il ya mieux
mais on sera taxée
de la politique comme moi tu sais
comment ça fonctionne bien sûr qu'à une
forme de domination des hommes et qui
sont avec une forme de violence et de
blagues dans ce
temps-là mieux que je connais toi tu me
parles à lui mieux dater les ont achetés
par les milieux ponote qu'honeywell côté
comme ça que ça se passe bien sûr
souvent les femmes sont plus souvent des
collaboratrices les hommes parce qu'ils
ont du pouvoir ont la sensation qu'ils
ont aussi le pouvoir sur leurs
collaboratrices ou leurs collaborateurs
parce que ça va aussi dans les deux sens
et donc il ya un traitement très négatif
les choses ont changé depuis mis tous
les comportements ont changé mais moi
j'ai vue d'aider des endroits où tu
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein d'hommes et
tout à coup une femme arrive et c'est
vraiment et bien sûr qu'elle a plein
d'histoires comme ça et des femmes qui
parfois sont comme elles sont en
soumission si tu veux hiérarchique et
que c'est leur gagne pain et qu'elles
ont des gosses à nourrir et bâle disent
rien et ça arrive très souvent et
heureusement c'est en train de changer
cd vérité quand même on peut pas dire
parce que ça arrive très souvent ce que
des reliques et les p tits oui donc
c'est de m'entraîner on peut l'écouter
c'est de ça dont on va l'écouter
et des phrases plus courtes et c'est pas
btpi siens mais c'est vrai on n'est pas
sur ces news là j'aime beaucoup c'est
nous mais là c'était pmp ça va vite on
doit vite le ballon pardon mais
politique ou pas politique mais c'est
quelque chose que je trouve
personnellement insupportable c'est
cette nouvelle mode de mitu maintenant
c'est d'accuser non seulement ceux qui
sont accusés mais ce qui était
potentiellement au courant et on les
traite de complices alors de coupables
pardon mais les mots ont un sens
complices dans une affaire de viol voilà
moi je pense à quelqu'un qui participe
au viol voilà là c'est des gens qui
était vaguement au courant donc ça veut
dire quoi si on a eu vent de
comportement problématique de la part de
quelqu'un ça veut dire quoi qu'il faut
mener une enquête soit même qu'il faut
les laisser rouler dans la
hiérarchie mais supérieurs hiérarchiques
en question quand tu la laisses aller
c'est comme dans une entreprise
veut dire toute la nuance et qu'est ce
que ça veut dire être au courant
effectivement si on dit voilà j'ai été
témoin d'un viol j'ai assisté un viol
dénoncé quand on dit voilà ce qu'est ce
que tu fais ma minimale qui balaye pas
d'un revers de main la parole de la
femme quand sonne c'est une chose dont
tu m'étonnes qu'ils croient que parce
que là ils n'ont aucune malice out
management oloron lui a dit on ne te
crois pas on croit en revanche la parole
de l'homme de kahrizak qui dit partout
que vous avez eu une histoire et tu la
vis mal parce qu'en règle générale une
femme hèle wieman séparation c'est une
hystérie passe assez nettement
les accordailles il a commencé à réussir
complètement en désaccord avec vous il
ya une sanction il ya eu la sanction
elle dit qu'elle a refusé avant elle a
été sanctionné financièrement sa réserve
parlementaire qui était attribué par
monsieur cahuzac a été réduite à rien
donc là on est carrément dans
une soumission d'une puissance à
quelqu'un qui est dominée si c'est vrai
c'est extrêmement grave regardez-vous
décrété que cette non c'est à 10,6 en
vrai c'est très grave voilà si c'est
vrai voilà vous avez tout dit comme si
ces gens mais c'est toujours pareil non
mais vous avez tout dit mais c'est moi
je suis à 2000% avec aurélie filippetti
si c'est vrai mais sa réserve année
dominée au delà de leurs maux mais le
gym ne pas demander pardon c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on comprend pourquoi si
une femme parle elle a forcément raison
non mais pas forcément hors lo ramallah
pas forcément du temps des fêtes toi tu
dis aussi si c'est vrai on n'en sait
rien tu as fait donc pardon n'est pas
tout
reconnais qu'à reconnais que c'est juste
un retour de balancier parce que pendant
des années et des amis c'est quand
l'homme parle et qu'il avait forcément
raison et la femme monte
systématiquement c'est ce que on disait
partout et on avait du mal à recueillir
la parole des femmes parce qu'elle
n'allait même pas jusqu'au commissariat
parce qu'ils aient de toute façon ils
opèrent par cavalli